Yeah.
Today we're going to talk about what is arguably the most important event of the
first part of our course.
The conversion of Constantine,
the Roman emperor to Christianity important not because of Constantine's own
particular opinions.
The fact that he embraced Christianity is as we'll see,
a little hard to explain on purely strategic grounds,
but its importance is that it represents a permanent change.
It represents the beginning of the Christianization of the Roman Empire,
a very unexpected result because not only had Christianity had been illegal in
the,
uh,
prior history of the empire that is to say for over 250 years.
But of course the,
uh,
God man Jesus had been put to death by the forces of the Roman Empire.
And as we've discussed Roman religion with its emphasis on what we've called
civic polytheism or the performance of ceremonies in public ceremonies that have
to do with local patriotism,
emperor worship,
the tradition of the Olympian gods.
And above all,
polytheism was very foreign to Christianity.
The Christian religion thus seemed to be a kind of annoying at the phenomenon of
Roman society when in fact with this event Constantine's conversion,
uh,
it becomes,
the first a tolerated religion,
then a favored religion and very quickly,
uh,
within the course of the fourth century Aad,
the official and almost the only religion of the Roman Empire.
How can this be?
We'll discuss both the specific events today and uh,
their meaning and how they play out.
Uh,
we recall then that what is called paganism that traditional religion of the
Roman empire was polytheistic,
not as many gods ceremonial had a lot of local variation and it was eclectic.
Okay.
Eclectic meaning that you could worship different gods and different places,
different gods for different purposes,
different Gods for different times of your life.
There was a certain emotional vacuum or at least a perceived vacuum in this
religion because it seemed to deny individual a longing and longing in general.
That longing,
that sense internally that there is more to life than there appears to be.
So that many adherence of other religions including but not limited to
Christianity,
believed that some part of their,
uh,
body,
was immortal or the soul was immortal or that the immortal soul had to be healed
by religion and not,
um,
uh,
that religion should simply be a pathway to good fortune or to easing the
anxieties of the material world.
So Christianity we've said is not so much other worldly focused on heaven.
It is that,
but even more important perhaps is it's inner ness.
It's inner worldliness,
the sense that people have a interior soul that yearns for something eternal and
more significant.
And then Christianity was accompanied by others,
so called mystery religions,
religions that also spoke to an immaterial heroic,
um,
non civic,
non urban type of Pie attain Mithra Ism for example,
or the worship of the mother goddess,
uh,
Sibley.
Christianity had certain advantages in terms of reaching a population,
the promise of an afterlife,
the commitment that it demanded of people,
uh,
a religion that appealed both to the elite and to the common people and a very
strong local organization.
But Christianity was alien to the Roman Empire.
The Romans did not always persecute Christianity as they did under Diocletian,
but they found Christianity Alien.
Uh,
they didn't like the fact that Christianity was intolerant.
Every other religion of the Roman Empire with one exception accepted other gods.
If you worship Isis,
you had nothing against other people worshiping Jupiter.
If you worship a Sibley,
you had nothing against other people worshiping Mithra.
But Christianity of course,
ridiculed all of these gods.
The only other religion that was like this was Judaism,
but Judaism made some accommodations with the Roman Empire,
recognize the authority of the Roman emperor and um,
did not defy the state in the way that Christianity at least appeared to.
And Christianity was not a Roman religion in many of the ways that it rejected
worldliness,
rejected engagement in or enjoyment of the material world,
the pleasures of the theater,
the circus,
the celebrations of civic paganism,
emperor worship,
law courts.
Well,
law courts may not be pleasurable,
but the sort of civic involvement of the emperor and the empire are rejected by
Christianity.
Christianity,
when you see what Roman pagans right about it is a kind of killed your religion.
It's a religion of people who seem to have their eyes focused on anything but
the actual process of getting ahead in Roman society.
Yeah.
All of this,
not withstanding,
it should be emphasized that Christianity was not persecuted constantly,
nor was the persecution.
Very intense.
We have Niro in the late sixties,
d the Dessi and persecution of the mid third century.
And of course the great persecution under Diocletian
Christianity received just enough persecution when might say to,
uh,
fortify it's spirit to give it some backbone,
but not enough to break it.
Constantine emerged from the chaos following Diocletian's abdication.
Diocletian as you'll recall,
had created this four man rule,
the tetrarchy in order to divide what was perceived as an excessively large
empire with an excessively large administrative structure.
But the tetrarchy,
uh,
was at least we can say with hindsight,
doom to failure.
Uh,
these four emperors would not cooperate.
They would tend to be rivals.
Constantine was the son of one of the CAESARS and one of the subordinates,
remember there are two August die to Caesars.
His father was,
Constantine has Cloris who was appointed when the tetrarchy began in the west.
And two 93,
so there was an Augustus of the West and the Caesar of the West,
the Caesar of the West was constant.
Tineas.
Cloris,
the young constant team was sent east to serve the eastern Augustus who
succeeded Diocletian,
uh,
go [inaudible]
Constantine was left out of the succession when Diocletian abdicated.
Gillary is appointed somebody else.
And Constantine rebelled.
Constantine,
uh,
in three Oh six,
raised an army in faraway Britain,
marched on Gaul and eventually was grudgingly recognized by goal areas as
Caesar.
At the same time,
another disinherited son of an Augustus man named Max [inaudible] rebelled
in Rome.
Okay.
And I will not burden you with the whole,
uh,
working out of these intrigues of the findings of armies of the corals of
Augusta and Caesar's.
But basically,
um,
in the,
uh,
in three 11 Gillary us who had been ill with cancer,
died and Clarius,
uh,
was succeeded by an emperor in the east,
named Las sinneas
and lascivious allowed Constantine to deal with the user per Max Census in the
West.
So we have [inaudible] in the east and three 11,
and then in the west,
Constantine.
And Max Census fighting it out.
Galleriest has dot.
Constantine defeated Max sense just out of battle,
not far from Rome.
The Battle of the mill vion bridge
battle,
the [inaudible] bridge in three 12 and Constantine was now Augustus in the west
La [inaudible] Augustus in the east.
The Battle of the mill vion bridge is the context for whatever it happened that
changed Constantine's mind about his religious orientation.
Just before the battle of the Melvin bridge,
something happened.
There are two stories that purport to explain the event.
One is that Constantine had a dream and in this dream an angel spoke to him and
ordered him to paint a a symbol combining the Greek letter chi and the Greek
letter row on his um,
uh,
right,
on his,
uh,
soldiers shields the row the are in Greek and the Chi,
written as an x.
The two letters,
uh,
symbolize or at least are taken later to symbolize Christ whose first,
the first letter being a Chi,
the second row,
the second version,
which is later met his later in circulation as a story but seems perhaps to have
been attested by the emperor himself to,
uh,
his biographer.
Eusebius.
Uh,
according to Ucbs,
uh,
Constantine was marching with his army before the battle and he,
along with the army saw across in the sky and super imposed on the sun against
which background the cross appeared,
where the words in this sign you will conquer,
uh,
hard to say which version if either,
is um,
what Constantine thought happened to him.
The argument for the second one is partly Eusebius is description,
partly the fact that angels in a dream or a standard kind of story.
Uh,
on the other hand,
the Chi Rho symbol is not previously a sign of Christianity.
So that the very fact that there isn't a background to that,
that,
uh,
this is something that we hear of now for the first time might indicate that
that's the true story.
But more important than what actually happened,
uh,
is that there's no reason to doubt Constantine's sincerity.
There is no reason to believe that this was a calculating,
cynical or politically astute move.
This is not because Constantine wasn't devious,
he was,
but because it's hard to imagine any emperor thinking that Christianity was a
good idea
because Christianity was subversive of Roman values and it was purse
particularly subversive of the values of the Roman army whose crucial aid
Constantine depended on and of which Constantine had to be the leader,
not only in order to defeat Mac sensuous,
but simply to survive in power.
Christianity was pacifist at this time.
It took more literally than it would later.
The admonitions of Christ in the gospels,
not to fight,
not to,
uh,
hit back,
not to engage oneself in the pursuit of worldly gain by means of violence.
But it's hard to imagine anything more unlikely than an emperor becoming
Christian and gaining the support of his followers.
Now,
that doesn't mean that Constantine became some sort of monk interpreted.
The gospels,
literally told his soldiers to put down their weapons.
It's clear the Constantine regarded the Christian God,
much as other emperors had regarded,
say,
the invincible son or the genius of the divine emperor or any other Pagan Deity
that brought victory in war.
Constant team like all emperors,
saw himself as a child of fortune.
As someone who was favored by fortune depended on fortune and who needed to
placate to mollify,
to please whatever God it was the controlled fortune.
What's unusual is that he would deem the Christian God to be this sort of God,
a leader of war,
a giver,
a victory in battle,
a companion to the emperor.
Uh,
none of this would seem at first glance to be likely in Christianity.
The fact that not only does it work,
but that it would work for centuries later is just part of the cataclysmic
nature of this event.
Or if not cataclysmic,
at least unexpected.
Constantine was not ignorant.
He's someone who had studied philosophy,
uh,
who was quite literate,
knew Greek,
pretty well,
familiar with Latin literature,
but nevertheless he was obviously a man of affairs is not a,
you know,
he's not a,
uh,
an intellectual contemplative person pouring over philosophy books.
He's a man of power,
decisiveness strategy,
uh,
and not,
a little cruelty and brutality.
And we can see that after his conversion experience,
and indeed I should point out he did beat Max Centers.
He accepted the Christian God.
He went to battle with the usurper and he defeated him.
But even after his victory,
he doesn't become in every respect a totally committed Christian,
at least in terms of the symbols of power of his office.
His coins,
for example,
which are a very good mark of propaganda and self or regard,
his coins kept the imagery of the earlier pagan deity associated with the
emperor,
the invincible son after a little while.
And you start to see the invincible sun on one side of the coin and the cross on
the other.
And only later in his reign do we have just the cross
Constantine's first substantive act as a Christian or as someone who favored the
Christian Church was the edict of tolerance.
The edict of tolerance or edict of toleration issued at Milan in three 13 was
jointly the product of Constantine and Lavania.
So now the two last guys standing the Augustus of the East [inaudible] and uh,
Constantine,
the Augustus of the West [inaudible] was a pagan and no did not share
Constantine's bizarre enthusiasm,
but all right.
You know,
if he wanted to tolerate Christianity,
this was fun.
This was part of their,
um,
I'm sorry.
It's not Lavania is Bonnie.
This is a philosopher.
Sinneas
okay.
Listen to his Constantine and listening.
Yes.
Listen,
this was a pagan,
but he was willing to go along with toleration at this point of Christianity was
legalized.
Okay.
But in the West,
constant team came to favor the church and do more than merely accepted as
legal.
For example,
he returned property confiscated in the dye,
queasy Yanik persecution.
He exempted the church from state taxation and incredible gift and allowed
church officials,
bishops,
and others to use the imperial communications system,
the so called post system whereby they could get fresh horses to go from one
place to another,
greatly speeding up their journeys and uh,
um,
making the journeys,
uh,
an effect chargeable to the state.
Constantine left the pagan and ceremonial center of Rome alone for the time
being at least,
and built two great basilicas on its outskirts.
One Saint Peters,
the Saint Peters that stands today is of course a product of the renaissance and
the Baroque.
But the old church,
uh,
that was,
um,
I've destroyed in the 16th century,
uh,
was a bat of Constantine.
And he also built the latter and basilica both of these outside the walls of
Rome
as we'll discuss.
He also attempted to mediate in disputes involving the church.
Okay.
He never,
however,
completely marginalized the old religions.
He emphasize the diversity of religious practice.
He didn't require a single form of worship,
but by the time he died in three 37,
uh,
the pace of conversions was such that,
perhaps as much as half of the empire had,
uh,
embraced Christianity.
And this brings us to a crucial question,
of course,
that we'll be discussing really throughout the semester.
And that is what was the effect of Constantine's conversion on the church or
beyond the mirror event of three 12.
What did it mean for the church to go from persecuted minority to established
majority?
What explains Constantine's ability not only to change the course of the Roman
religious practice and tendencies,
but to do so permanently for the church?
Was this turnaround,
a providential sign or a kind of Trojan horse gift in which the Church would now
be so tied to the official culture that it would never be able to shake off Rome
administration and bureaucracy to get back to its original charismatic
individual powerful foundations.
Okay.
The era of Constantine establishes the problem of the Church and the world for
the Middle Ages and indeed beyond this problem is,
is the church a collection of special people who have their eyes fixed on heaven
or is it a kind of universal society?
Uh,
that is hard to distinguish from just worldliness and engagement with the world
of business life,
death,
uh,
and other banalities,
it is Saint Augustine who is going to deal with this most forcibly in terms of
theory,
but that's a century later.
So 75 years later,
externally,
the church adopted very quickly to success.
We can see this in terms of the pace of conversion.
As I said,
not only were 50% of the people,
perhaps Christian by three 37 when Constantine died,
but by three,
nine day,
the time,
uh,
of the Emperor Theodosius or,
on his death,
three 95.
Okay.
Probably 90% of the population was at least nominally Christian.
The reasons for this success,
in other words,
how could Constantine's particular gesture have such a decisive impact?
Um,
some of this has to do with Christianity's willingness to adopt to the customs
of the empire.
Some of it may have to do with the weakness of the official religion of Rome and
of the urban elites who were it's chief support.
MMM.
Those who held out against Christianity were on the one hand,
people in the rural areas.
So peasants who is fundamental beliefs tended to be directed to agriculture,
local deities,
deities that controlled the weather and water and things like that.
The army for reasons I've just said that is the,
um,
uh,
Christianity is not at first glance congenial to people who fight for a living.
And then the third group that held out where the intelligentsia,
particularly of Rome and Athens,
the people who had a substantial cultural investment in a Greek and Roman
philosophy,
the intellectual side of the old elite,
well,
Konstantin fell out with [inaudible] and after some small skirmishes,
a Constantine managed to defeat him at a,
a place called Christopolous.
And three 24,
he listened.
He has fled from the battlefield.
Constantine's forces caught up with him and listen to yes.
Was executed.
Um,
this event,
this battle of Cassopolis
important in itself.
Okay.
Oh No.
I longer important in itself was even more important because it showed
Constantine the importance of the small fortress city of Byzantine,
not far away Byzantium
who
is,
uh,
the,
ancestor of the city that Constantine would found their constant to no bull
and of course modern Istanbul and it's
okay.
20th,
21st century incarnation.
Byzantium commanded a strategic point of access east,
west and north south.
It was the point of access between the uh,
uh,
Black Sea and the Mediterranean.
The boss for us is a narrow straight that separates Europe from Asia,
Byzantium Constantinople,
Istanbul a stands on the,
uh,
West Bank,
the European side,
but it commands and controls the channel by which anyone would go from the
Mediterranean to the Black Sea.
And since the Black Sea is the gateway to Central Asia in an effect,
controls communication between two commercial strategic and military zones.
It also controls the route from the Balkans,
southeastern Europe into Asia into specifically in this case,
Asia minor or the Asian part of what's now Turkey.
Byzantium is there for strategically located in terms of communication and at
the same time located so that an army can get to two of the most dangerous
frontiers of the Roman Empire in a reasonable amount of time without having to
commit itself to one or the other.
Totally.
It is not far from the Danube frontier,
which was,
as we said,
one of the points at which the empire met the barbarian tribes and which the
Empire had sort of decided on as its natural frontier and Constantinople was
also not that far from the eastern frontier of the Roman Empire,
the frontier with Persia which ran along what's now eastern Turkey,
Armenia,
western Iran and Iraq.
It was the city also within the richest part of the empire.
As we said,
one of the problems of the empire in it's later years,
it's later centuries,
was that the east was becoming richer,
more urban,
more commercial of the West was lagging behind,
more rural,
less successful in its commerce.
Constant team wanted an eastern capital for both strategic and for economic
reasons,
for strategic reasons,
having to do with the movement of the armies and the protection of the frontier
for economic reasons having to do with taxation and administration.
The city of Rome itself was somewhat isolated,
strangely enough,
since of course the whole empire had grown up around Rome,
but Rome was the historical origin of the empire,
but not in the fourth century.
And it's actual living capital.
Uh,
it,
it would be too much to compare it say to the relationship between Portugal and
Brazil.
It's not quite that lopsided,
but you know,
Brazil is a former colony of Portugal.
They speak the language of Portugal.
Yet on the world stage,
Brazil is larger than Portugal,
more important than Portugal,
richer now,
uh,
than Portugal.
Uh,
so whatever preeminence Portugal or its capital Lisbon has within the world of
culture,
no Brazilian would take Lisbon to be the be all and end all of the Portuguese
cultural world.
So similarly,
by this time,
Rome has become less important,
even within the western empire and this relocation of the capitol to
Constantinople.
The relocation of the Capitol to the East is significant because it shows us
the,
um,
permanent result of the tetrarchy as we've said,
Diocletian's experiment was a failure in the sense that the emperors and
Caesar's would not cooperate and such a scheme was never tried again.
But the division of the empire between East and West would be something that
would eventually become permanent.
It's first traces are with Diocletian and that's one reason why we begin the
course with him.
It is also something that continues under Constantine without the addition of
the Caesars.
Constantine ruled over the whole empire.
He did not divided himself,
but he facilitated it's conceptual and eventually real political division by
creating a new realm,
a new capital in,
uh,
the former fortress of Byzantium,
a town that he modestly named after himself.
Constantinople as this town was called,
was planned to be a new Rome like Rome.
It would have a forum,
it would have civic spaces.
It would have,
uh,
races and sporting events.
It would have imperial palaces and gardens.
Uh,
it would have victory columns,
triumphal arches,
aqueducts,
the whole panoply of classical civilization.
It wouldn't have a whole lot of temples.
Churches would be more important than temple's,
not the constant team,
totally banned tempos from Constantinople.
But these were knocked the highlights of the city.
It is a,
an ideological statement like other planned great in perio sites.
So we could compare it to in the modern world,
Saint Petersburg created by the czar's as a certain kind of statement with a
certain kind of plan and a certain kind of look evoking western Europe in
particular or they're cy,
not a town at all,
but rather a kind of palace city fit for the King of France.
At this point,
Constantine becomes a considerably more devout and somewhat more intolerant.
We start to see him interact with the Christian Church in its most intimate way.
That is to say doctrine.
Yeah.
Constantine is appealed to by the Donna tests schismatics or what we're calling
them schismatics or heretics as they were decided to be from North Africa.
But Donna tests taught that the,
uh,
priests who had,
given over the scriptures under persecution at the time of Diocletian were not
legitimate priests.
And we'll talk later about the implications of this.
The implications briefly are that,
um,
the church cannot cover for priests that the office is not greater than a man.
If the man has,
can mitigate a,
such as what was called treason,
the handing over of the scriptures to the persecutors,
he no longer can baptize validly.
He no longer can perform the sacraments with validity.
A donatism then implies that a,
the church itself,
uh,
is really just as good as the character of its officials.
The donnas just we're strong in north Africa and they appeal to Constantine
against decisions that had been made against them within the church.
The fact that Christians are appealing to the emperor already as early as three
17 shows the acceptance of the emperor as a Christian arbiter,
but it also shows a kind of in retrospect,
dangerous intermingling of what we would consider to be church and state.
Similarly,
Constantine would get involved in controversies over the relationship between
God,
the father and Christ,
the son.
This too,
we'll go into in more detail,
but this is the Aryan heresy Arion with an I not with a y at named after a
priest named areas who taught that
while Christ is God,
he is in some sense subordinate to God the father.
This is a controversy over the nature of the Trinity in which Christ is seen as
coming from God as emanating from God.
And uh,
as I think I warned at the beginning of the course,
if you don't like doctrinal and theological controversy,
uh,
you know,
I'll try to spare you all its ins and outs,
but you can't teach this course without it.
Again,
what we're talking about now is not the content of Arianism who embraced it,
why,
but the fact that the emperor gets involved in these controversies.
On the one hand,
this shows the quick adaptation of the church to imperial rule.
On the other hand,
because Constantine was able to solve neither the donotist nor the Aryan
division,
at least not definitively,
and at least not yet.
It shows how difficult it was for an emperor who could conquer all of his
secular rivals who could control this vast realm from Gibraltar to the Tigris
and Euphrates,
uh,
but couldn't get a bunch of North African peasants to obey his orders about how
to worship or Egyptian priests either.
Constantine we can see is frustrated by this.
Can See in the reading from Jones his difficulties in dealing with this in the
usual way,
the usual way being the emperor has petitioned by people.
He appoints some arbiter's or judges.
The judges make a decision and then the emperor announces to these people that
that's what it's going to be.
Problem is that of course people like the dinosaurs were already used to
martyrdom,
threatening them with imprisonment,
threatening them with torture,
denouncing them,
trying to use the,
uh,
awesome awe inspiring power of the emperor against them.
Oh,
it was not going to be sufficient.
Nevertheless,
constant team,
far from abandoned and Christianity and frustration becomes more and more
engaged in trying to,
if not officially Christianize the empire at least,
um,
legislate as a Christian emperor.
By three 30,
he has come to see himself,
not merely as an emperor who has a kind of peculiar favor or a peculiar God that
is following him,
but as the implementer of the mission of the church.
So for example,
he starts promulgating laws against married men having concubines ineffective or
the seduction of wards by their guardians or a punishing rape by burning all
orientation towards sexual crimes that shows a more Christian horror of them
have.
Then the more easygoing Roman attitude,
Constantine favors the church in acts,
legislation recommended by the church,
favors the bishops.
And even uh,
in uh,
three 20 or the three twenties presides over the first Ecumenical Council of
bishops of the church called at Nascio across the boss for us from
Constantinople,
the Ecumenical Council of Nicea cold to deal with the area and controversy.
And here we see Constantine as something,
uh,
different from an emperor,
nearly the companion of Christ or the companion of God,
but the emperor as in some sense head of the church,
Constantine appears up the council,
he is a deferred to by the bishops.
Nevertheless,
he is not himself a bishop.
He is not himself.
However imperial,
the church may look able to legislate by himself for the church because unlike
many other religions,
and certainly when we come to Islam,
you'll see the contrast.
The political of the Roman Empire is not the designated leader of the religious
practice of the church.
Okay.
Because he is not a priest.
Now,
uh,
who is the designator leader of the church is not clear yet.
Certainly it's not yet the pope.
And in,
uh,
the three twenties,
it is the collectivity of bishops.
But in that case,
then some bishops have more power than others.
Nevertheless,
this is the beginning of an era in which we have a blending but not a total a
equivalency of secular rule,
imperial rule on the one hand and spiritual or church rural on the other.
And that's one of the things that of course characterizes our image of the
Middle Ages,
a period in which the church and the state were overlapping,
if not actually fused
Constantine in relation to Diocletian to conclude,
uh,
differences and similarities.
Obviously there's similarities are great.
Both Diocletian and Constantine remade the Roman empire as a much more tightly
administered state,
a more bureaucratically complicated state,
and a more militarized state.
Constantine continued Diocletian's military and administrative structure
like Diocletian.
In order to do this,
he had to rely on very heavy taxation.
If anything,
has taxation,
had to be greater because he had exempted the church and it's clergy and someone
was going to have to make up the difference.
But Diocletian had persecuted the Catholic Church,
whereas a Constantine would favorite.
And that is of course a crucial difference.
On the other hand,
even here,
there are some connections under Diocletian.
The emperor was a god.
The emperor was a distantly glimpsed figure.
He was no longer even in pretense,
first citizen God just like you and me handshaker baby kiss her or anything like
that.
But this was also true with Constantine.
Constantine.
Uh,
uh,
two had a ceremonial distant and because of his association with the Church,
semi sacred status,
he couldn't be worshiped as a god to be sure,
but he was something a bit more than a merely a,
a follower of Christianity.
Constantine the tetrarchy.
But he really set the seal on the division of the Empire East and West,
as we've just said,
by the establishment of Constantinople.
And finally,
counseling team was a little more successful economically.
Diocletian,
uh,
did not have the means available to Constantine who had a certain amount from
the old pagan temple treasures that he was able to confiscate.
And also,
uh,
by virtue of his victory over listen as he was able to rule,
a pretty tightly over the empire.
The fourth century often is seen as a period of decline because we're focused.
We historians are focused on the collapse of the Roman Empire in the late fifth
century,
but obviously people in three 37,
the year that Constantine died,
did not know that enforced 76 the western empire would collapse.
They did not know that in four 10,
Visigoths would invade and plunder the city of Rome.
Uh,
no more than we have the faintest idea of what's going to happen.
75 or a hundred years from now,
from their point of view of the empire had been restored.
The empire,
which had been endangered in the third century by invasions,
inflation,
uh,
armed forces out of control,
chaotic imperial succession was now stable,
was clear who the emperor was.
The barbarians had been pushed back behind the frontiers.
Trade culture,
civilization seemingly flourished.
And if we trust the,
uh,
impressions we have of contemporaries,
both formal written work and informal things like the slogans that people put in
their dining room,
mosaics,
for example,
a good times had been restored.
This seems to be the constant theme,
and I emphasize this because again,
it's a lesson in how the history cannot be seen from the front backwards.
You can't use hindsight to tell what people should have felt.
People in the fourth century,
at the time of Constantine,
we're optimistic no more.
So those people who would embrace Christianity as the coming thing,
as the religion of,
uh,
not only truth,
but if success,
what is odd is of course,
that thus far Christianity would have seemed to be unlikely.
Christianity would have seemed to be alien from the empire.
And even if some emperor embraced it for weird reasons of its own,
his own wouldn't have seemed to have been the most favorable,
uh,
context for the preservation of the empire.
And indeed,
of course,
the empire would fail in the West within a century and a half or so of the
embrace of Christianity.
And it's no surprise then that the Roman,
uh,
English historian of the Roman Empire,
Edward Gibbon,
who's decline and fall of the Roman empire,
sort of sets the agenda for any course like this one.
It's no accident that gibbon blame Christianity for the fall of the empire,
but indeed in the fourth century,
it seemed that Christianity was one of the forces that had saved the empire.
And not only that,
as we will see as this course unfolds,
much of what was preserved from the debacle of four 76 and successive problems
of the preservation of civilization would be preserved through the action of the
church.
Thanks very much.